throughout much of human history sages
have spoken about the mystical
experience perhaps the most meaningful
experience that human beings are capable
of having a mystical experience is an
encounter with the transcendent Triton's
an encounter with the numinous when Otto
rank described as the mysterium
tremendum and a solution of reality when
the doors of perception are cleansed and
the mystical experience has some
characteristics some persisted hallmarks
that always show up no matter the
culture or worldview and belief system
of whoever is having it so there's these
common attributes that show up with
mystical experiences they are the
following the mystical experience is
characterized by feelings of cosmic
unity feelings of oneness with elders
feelings of interconnection mystical
experience is characterized by feelings
of transcendence time-space the mine
freed from the shackles of the ego
freed from the constraints of time and
space the mystical experience is
characterized by positive wound lifting
right a feeling and bliss a feeling of
ecstasy a feeling of gratitude right
your magic the mystical experience is
characterized by feelings of the sea
connecting with the divine mystical
experience is characterized by
ineffability a feeling that you can't
quite put it into words and it's an
experience beyond language you can't
clothe it with language the mystical
experience is characterized by feelings
of paradoxically feelings where you can
hold multiple perspectives in mind at
once where contradictions are ricans ire
where you can conceive of opposites and
somehow hold them in mind at once
basically experience is characterized by
its fluid quality it's something can
emerge to dissolve just as quickly it's
it's a finite experience a mystical
experience is characterized by feelings
of transformative change that are
lasting so even though it's a temporary
experience a person is forever
transformed new perspectives our glimpse
new visionary understanding is felt and
and so a person is forever made better
personal feels like they've seen the
light whereas one's when we're blind now
we can see
and finally a mystical experience leaves
us with a quality of a noetic flavor
right there's this sense that what was
seen and what was understood and what
was felt
has some deeper veracity than everyday
reality has some kind of deeper meaning
beyond our normal literal grid there's a
sense that there is ultimate truth and
ultimate meaning to what was apprehended
and this lasts indefinitely so these are
the hallmarks of a mystical experience
something that as human beings we should
all aim to encounter at least once in
our lives because as David Foster
Wallace wrote the alternative is
unconsciousness the default setting the
rat-race
the constant gnawing sense of having had
and lost some infinite thing
[Music]